so as we were just discussing with the
house secretary from tomorrow all
arrivals at the UK borders will with a
few exceptions after quarantine for 14
days with the government arguing those
measures are necessary to avoid another
spike in corona virus infections
concerns have been raised daily about
the damage that this could do to
Airlines and the economy and the science
behind the move - well to discuss that
and more we're discussed by the we're
joined sorry by the shadow transport
secretary Jim McMahon thank you for
being on the program this morning and
keen to get on to the quarantine but I
just wanted to start with the
anti-racism protests that we've seen hit
in the United Kingdom and thousands of
people taking part yesterday the vast
majority of it was peaceful but there
were a few violent scenes and do you
condemn those about we fully understand
the emotional outcry and seeing what's
going on in America and of course people
feel passionately about that people want
to show solidarity and also people want
to make sure that in the UK we'll get
our own house in order to in terms of
those underlying inequalities that still
exist in many places and so of course
people want to be able to demonstrate
and show their voice and solidarity and
it's important to say that I mean cuz
you know some of the scenes that we've
seen are not acceptable in terms of
missiles being thrown but they will be a
tiny handful of the people that were
there to show solidarity and short piece
together yeah that's absolutely right of
course no one would disagree with that
I was just talking to the House
Secretary Mike Hancock he said he
although he has a lot sympathy with the
protests he doesn't believe the UK is a
racist society do you think it is I
think there are definitely pockets a
very deep rooted racism in this country
I wouldn't say it's well the majority
but where it exists it's very deep and
you know whether that's physically in
some communities whether that's online
in the way that many of our online
platforms just don't do anywhere near
enough to police that effectively it's
unavoidable to take at the racism exists
and in many places it's being allowed to
go on unchecked
and so we do need to face up to that
because if we don't face up to it we
can't put the measures in place to do
all that it feels like a time when
people do a lot of reflecting a lot of
soul-searching on you know what we can
do in our own lives to try and track or
tackle those structural
inequalities that we see and labor of
course has never elected a leader who
wasn't white and what do you think that
labor could do to try and help the
anti-racist cause and there are there
any things that you in particular are
you know reflecting on in your own life
well I think from a labor perspective we
are an open and inclusive party and if
your car Shadow Cabinet you've got seven
members from being communities on the
shadow cabinet you have a lot the
general Ludd chancellor is black himself
and i do think of it more the collective
after that I see really which is that we
all need to take personal and collective
responsibility but making sure that we
call out injustice and racism where we
see it but also that would take a more
concerted action to and dressy kind of
the inbuilt inequalities that we see
because for far too many people you know
the place where you were born your life
conditions on the day that you were born
will determine your whole life
experience through school through the
workplace and how long you're going to
live with you know with ten years less
than a counterpart in a different post
code you know there's some really deep
rooted in the courses in this country
that we've been very very slow to
address and even if you go back to 2017
and Theresa Mays Ridgid asperity order
you know very little action in my view
has been taken on actually as cementing
some of the recommendations in that and
we need to do far more now more than
40,000 people have died of Cove at 19 in
the United Kingdom and a
disproportionate number those deaths
were from people from black and minority
ethnic backgrounds and in a time when
we're socially distancing do you think
it's right that so many people touch the
streets in crowds gathering in large
groups yesterday I think first of all we
need to dispel some idea that the UK has
been in a bubble and all of a sudden
these group of people who are
demonstration have come out of that in a
way that is not representative of the
country a large I've got to tell you
from my own case work here in Alden you
know there are thousands of people in
all them that we hundreds of thousands
of people around the country who have
been going to work web social distance
and hasn't been maintained because the
questions
I feel like you're answering a slightly
different question do you think it is
right at a time when you know hundreds
of people are still being announced as
dying from coronavirus every day do you
think it's right that people touch the
streets in the way they did specifically
on that no I'm very clear that we are
really fearful that we're gonna get a
second spike in the virus we are not out
of the woods at all hundreds of people
are still dying every day in this
country and we all need to play our part
individually and collectively to make
sure that we don't risk that my point
was more that there are people who are
forced to break social distance and
every day to prove going through work
can out their everyday lives I can
adjust say in terms of equity MPs were
in Parliament lining up often breaking
social distancing because of the pinch
point in terms of upholding Democratic
responsibility we also need to
understand that you know peaceful
assembly is also very important have I
don't democrats democratic process as
well and so of course we don't want
anybody to break social distancing we
want to make sure we control the virus
but we also need to put it into
perspective as well okay now just to
move on to your Air Transport brief the
UK's bring you in a 14 day quarantine
for anyone arriving in the country or
from tomorrow we discussed it already in
the program is that something you
welcome and do you think people should
be looking a summer holiday abroad our
real concern is that the government just
haven't got a plan they seem to go from
one extreme to another so automatically
no restrictions you know up until only
couple of days ago we were the outlier
in terms of the world with having either
north or restrictions in place on or
partial restriction in place of there
were Serbia and Mexico and now we go to
the very blunt - it was a 14 day
quarantine
when 22 million people have come into
this country since the new year you know
even since a lockdown began 10 to 15
thousand people have been coming into
the country and so we do need to make
sure that whatever we do in terms of
interventions this evidence-based is a
proper plan in place and of course at
the exit is made clear and for aviation
it's also really important that we have
a sector deal to support the financial
consequences and hold off any job losses
in what's the very important part of our
economy and a very important part by the
way for our recovery
and face masks it's been announces all
it's also going to be compulsory on
public transport
I just want because you're talking a
little bit earlier about how MPs are in
Westminster and not always socially
distancing do you think it should be
compulsory for MPs to have face masks
well we're going to move to is to say
how much of the World Health
Organization have renewed their guidance
on a couple of days ago to say if you're
in a environment public transport or the
workplace where you can't maintain sort
of distance and then a face covering
will provide some degree of protection
not entirely very protection but a
degree of protection and a so I you know
I do think we need to review the way
that Parliament words I mean the
frustration with Parliament of course is
if it's at all a bondable then it should
be avoided and we can vote
electronically we can vote in 15 seconds
we don't have to be queuing up for 40
minutes a cyclamen being unsafe in my
view is awesome massively inefficient
way of working so [ __ ] in peace we're
face coverings then do you think cut in
the current situation well other coming
down on Monday from the Northwest where
of course the VRA is a huge concern for
people here down to London nothing the
question is well why wait if face
coverings are now required to keep
people safe on public transport
why wait a week am I more or less of a
risk this Monday that I'll be the
following Monday that's all I'm going to
do what I believe is the right thing
which is to wear a face covering on
public transport okay and just finally
and this week Jeremy Corbyn questioned
the impartiality of the equality and
human rights commission that's
conducting this inquire into the parties
handling of antisemitism claims he said
it was part of the government machine do
you agree with mr. kuban's
assessment and do you think that's going
to help the party win back the trust of
Jewish people I think the point is that
the review is taking place we take that
extremely serious like but more than
that there's a commitment to make sure
those recommendations are implemented
with sincerity and a commitment to make
sure that we right the wrong way Jewish
people don't feel that the Labour Party
can be a party for them and so we do
need to show concerted action and
Kirsten has been absolutely clear about
his commitment to that and will make
sure the quality so do you agree with
Jeremy Corbyn then that the equality and
human rights commission is part of the
government machine well of course it's
related to government but my view is
it'll act with integrity
it will look at the evidence base and it
will provide you know practical
solutions about what we can do to repair
the trust issue that we've got you know
it's only when you face up to these
issues can you address them burying the
head in the sand ignoring them
pretending of their even though we wish
they weren't there I'm afraid just
doesn't deal with it and so you know
we've got to be we've got to face up to
the issue that we've got we got to make
sure were practical steps in play to
rebuild that trust okay Jim it man thank
you very much for being on the program
today thank you